don't really know what the the
article was trying to say but what I
heard it saying was that we were pissing
out thousands of dollars of liquid gold
and I was going to be rich
this is not happening
I'm your host royal ahjumma
[Music]
tonight's episode is all about
she nails all the way from Philadelphia
PA just to read
[Music]
tonight I'm gonna tell a story the last
time I drank piss stop me if you've
heard this one first I'm gonna explain
how I went from being totally normal to
the kind of person that has a story
about drinking piss multiple stories
okay so like the first time I tried meth
I was 22 I was at a gig in Montana When
in Rome and I tried it on accident I
would never purposely try math I'm not a
scumbag I thought it was coke and I
thought it was coke cuz the guy that
gave it to me told me it was coke and
what kind of world are we living in if
you can't trust a stranger giving you
drugs so I do the line and the back of
my head catches on fire and I'm like did
you just slip me meth who slips people
so I yelled at him I was like I don't
even think you roofie right idiot
supposed to roofie girls he could
him not so they can help you take apart
your microwave okay so this is where
gets weird here's the thing don't
ever try meth because it's
awesome
and you won't want to stop I did the
accidental roofie meth and was just
addicted to meth for six years after
that like ruined my life I was just
trying to a pump with the club so I
could learn how to line dance or
whatever the they do in Montana now
I'm alone in my hotel room shaving off
my eyebrows and I get back home to
Portland Oregon I quit doing comedy so I
could pursue meth full-time really
seemed like that was gonna work out
better than it did I mean it probably
paid about the same I see we have
comedians in here tonight
it was crazy though cuz I was so high I
was high as so I didn't even
realize the gravity of what was
happening I felt like I had just
discovered the secret to happiness I got
home I was bragging to my friends and
family about my newfound meth habit
none of them were happy for me
then I just got defensive like well this
is who I am now so if you can't handle
whatever Marilyn Monroe quote
you can't take me at my methi asyou
don't deserve me when my trailer blows
up so my parents asked me to vacate
their basement before I start selling
off the TVs and and I move into the
sketchy meth hostel with multiple dudes
named shorty and I just go completely
off the rails
here's the thing though when you're high
on meth you can justify any kind of
behavior you can rationalize like
everything just makes sense I think it's
because your mind is so open like if you
watch a video on the Internet of
somebody vacuuming their front yard on
meth you're like that is crazy that's
because you're only using 6% of your
brain if you were firing off at 98% meth
capacity you would be like sock that
makes perfect sense my yard is filthy so
still nothing seemed amiss to me I'm
living with the shorties I've got no job
I've lost my driver's license I lost
contact with my family but I was in
daily communication with the aliens
blues and Grey's it was wild my teeth
fell out so fast it was like how I
imagine if a witch put a spell on you
they just crumbled like they were made
of sand in Hairspray houses
[Laughter]
sorry and my whole life revolved around
math all I cared about was met but I did
I was like yeah but like I'm only
snorting it that's practically
recreational I'm not like an addict like
those guys that smoked it look at them
they're a mess so when I started smoking
it
that was a socialistic I was I knew I
was like I'm gonna be here for a while
and I want to integrate into my meth
community yeah I like kind of plug-in
and it was a social thing for them they
would sit around and smoke meth and talk
about where they were gonna steal mail
that day it was like joining the
tweakers Elks Lodge you know so I was
like and by that point I've been doing
it long enough to know that as long as I
don't shoot up I'll be fine right so
when I start shooting up that was a
financial decision like she have to
smoke that all day it is not
cost-effective at all you can shoot up
once in the morning you're good for the
rest of the day it's probably the most
fiscally responsible decision I've made
as an adult if I'm being honest but I
have super small veins so I had to shoot
up in my neck yeah sorry I'm trying to
ease you guys in here
it gets way the worse shooting up
in your neck is inconvenient because
someone else has to do that for you and
the kind of people that possess the
skill set to hit you and your jugular
not the kind of people that are fun to
do meth with I was into like making
necklaces in collage art and they
were into like home invasions and stuff
pork so gets kind of dark around
this point and this is when I start
thinking like god there's got to be a
better way not like it's sober or
anything stupid just like a
better way to do meth so I was googling
it not enough information on the subject
but I came across this article and it
was talking it's like Time magazine or
something it was talking about the meth
epidemic and the reason that so many
people were switching from cocaine and
meth apparently some people had done
this on purpose and according to the
article the reason is because the meth
high lasts so long and according to the
article that's because your body can
metabolize coke but your body has no eye
you do a line and then it breaks it down
and you're only high until it starts
breaking it down but your body has no
idea what to do with Matt that's why
you're high so long because it goes in
meth and comes out meth and you get to
stay high that whole time so I don't
really know what the the article
was trying to say but what I heard it
saying was that we were pissing out
thousands of dollars of liquid gold
[Applause]
[Music]
and I was gonna be rich so I originally
set out to find the formula for
extracting meth from Tweaker piss and as
I'm collecting buckets of my friend's
urine once again there are no red flags
going off no thoughts that perhaps this
is symptomatic of my life spiraling out
of control I was proud of myself I was
like wow I am really thinking outside
the box
[Laughter]
this must be what Steve Jobs feels like
so after about ten days of trying to do
science I was like yeah chemistry is
hard I'm just gonna drink it from the
tap you're so grossed out it was my own
piss do some credit I was like labeling
it out of the bucket so the first time I
drank meth piss I got so high that I
went to the place and the matrix were
like they plugged their heads in and
nobody wears makeup but I went to the
real one
and I met my higher self and I met the
higher selves of like my friends and
and they taught me the true nature
of consciousness and the wiring under
the board
it was the most transcendental
experience I've ever had and I've done a
ton of psychedelics in case that's
not obvious I spent the whole day at the
matrix place and when I came down I was
so transformed by this experience that I
was just addicted to drinking meth piss
here's the thing don't ever drink meth
piss because it's fantastic and you
I did quit shooting up that day though
cuz there was like no point right I
started eating meth with a spoon out of
the bag because doing actual mess just
became a technicality to manufacturing
meth piss I had it down to a science it
was the second piss after you eat the
math that was the magical nectar I told
everyone about it I converted no one I
did get voted most likely to become a
bag lady by my fellow tweeters cuz by
that point I spent my days raging
against the reptilian agenda while
sipping on my pisser so the last time I
drank meth pissed I'll get to the point
where I'm walking around Southeast
Portland and it was I had to it was time
to harvest if you will and I didn't like
to do it in public restrooms because it
was hard to get a clean catch and the
only person that I knew that lived in
that neighborhood was my little sister
and my little sister at this point is
the only family member that I will speak
to because she's the only one I can be
sure isn't working for George Bush but
we are like complete opposites she is 20
years old she totally has her
together she has an apartment job car
boyfriend whatever I'm 27 I don't really
have to clarify that I didn't have my
together rollin up to her house to
drink piss
she's also embarrassed of me which
rightfully so when I knock on her door
I'm wearing my meth uniform which is a
bubblegum pink ballgown like prom dress
like puffs that like you know with tulle
and satin and out to here
Skechers a stolen FBI windbreaker
a Barbie backpack and a tiara the tiara
was because I didn't have any teeth left
you don't have a girl you gotta wear a
tiara because it draws the eyes upward
she answers the door and sees that it's
me and she's like um my friends are here
and they don't get it could you maybe
come back talk about your friends I just
need to use your bathroom and she was
like oh my god are you gonna shoot up
and I was like no I don't shoot up
anymore I'm living right she says fine
you have two minutes but I swear to god
you have to leave after that so I go in
there I waste my entire two minute
allotment just rifling through her
cupboards and Hermetic just trying to
find like some type of receptacle to
piss in she doesn't have a cup or
anything I'm like what kind of Barbara
cast bathroom operation you run in here
finally the only thing I can find is her
toothbrush holder I know right get a
cup so I knocked the
toothbrushes out of it it's like the
cheap plastic kind I'm talking about
comes like Walmart comes inside a
wastebasket with it like a shitty bath
mat you know it's right and it's got
four holes and it looks like that thing
is a lid
I only saw that there's a lid but trust
me it's not lid cuz I am like working
the plunger thing I can't get it off
that's your sliding down it's 90 degrees
she's banging on the door finally I take
her toothbrush and I'm like I'm just
gonna pop it off with the toothbrush I
snap her toothbrush and a half and I'm
like what the is with everything in
this bathroom I guess I'm just gonna
have to freakin go in you know so I
don't know if you've ever tried to piss
and prayer not
but it's like that right that thing at
the carnival where you got to shoot the
water into the clown's round mouth okay
only instead of witness stuffed-animal
you get piss on your hands so I get
about half of it in there I go to throw
it back and I see inside of the holes
that there's like like old toothpaste
jerky and dust and and I was like
ah this is gross I can't drink this
without a chaser
so I hide it in her wastebasket and I go
out of the bathroom she falls in and I'm
like woah woah woah don't go in there
nothing weird is happening I just need a
coke and then I'm gonna go in there and
finish my normal thing that I was doing
and then I'll be out of your hair so I
go I get the coke of course she scurries
in there she finds the broken toothbrush
and the eight ball my pissed so when I
come back in she's just like
overreacting
kicking me out of her house and I'm
not really listening but then I tuned in
all of a sudden is she's like you're
almost 30 years old you need to wake up
and get your together
to which I replied all right so in five
years I've done horrible things to get
drugs
I've been intermittently homeless I've
had Ukrainians try to kill me and I'm
addicted to drinking my piss and
apparently all I needed this whole time
was someone to suggest that maybe I
don't do this anymore
it was the world's laziest intervention
even my sister was like wait really
and I was like yeah well I mean I can
recognize that this is got weird
you're chastising me while holding a
bathroom accessory filled with my urine
I could probably use a break and that
was it I got clean that night as 12
years ago
well technically technically it was the
next day because I totally drink that
pee when she wasn't looking but that was
the last time that I drank piss thank
you very much